las personas en este lugar vienen de
descendencia extranjera
bueno era muy niña cuando mis padres
decidieron venir a argentina no me
acuerdo la edad y las razones económicas
siempre económicas incluso hoy 2018
muchos de mis compatriotas siguen
viajando buscando mejores oportunidades
cuando tenía 11 años mis papás volvieron
a perú a buscarnos a mi hermana ya mí
para traernos con ellos a argentina
ese día fue uno de los días más tristes
de mi vida ya que tendría que dejar a
mis abuelos a quienes en ese momento yo
consideraba como mis verdaderos padres
debe ser que la ausencia de mis padres
marcó mi vida
- y lloré mucho me acuerdo en la
terminal
había muchas muchos niños llorando
esposas esposos separados cuatro días de
viajes escuchando historias llanto me
acuerdo cuando llegamos a chile
mi mamá me dijo que había posibilidades
de que no pasáramos y que si eso llegaba
a pasar no deberíamos de llorar nos
miramos con mi hermana y
tuvimos la esperanza de que nos
regresaran cuando hicimos la fila había
muchos colectivos con muchos que venían
desde perú para en busca de mejores
oportunidades
y si pasamos nos tocó
tenían que enseñar una bolsa de viaje
una bolsa de viaje es una cantidad de
dinero en dólares que demuestra que
estás entrando al país como turista
cuando toco nuestro turno nosotros
pasamos
ese día fue otra despedida muchas
personas separadas niños volviendo a
llorar
me acuerdo una valla que se levantaba
para pasar a la argentina
ese día me preguntaba y conocí lo que
era una frontera también decía que
estaba malo porque dividía a las
personas y causaba dolor y llanto cuando
llegamos a argentina todo era distinto
ustedes viajaron la afuera fueron al
extranjero le gustaba la comida a las
calles
era lindo no seguramente estuvieron
semanas meses años pero siempre
quisieron regresar
ustedes serán extranjeros cuando alguien
viaja fuera de su país y regresa es
extranjero pero cuando uno decide
quedarse a vivir no lo es
yo cuando llegué me sentía extranjera
era extraña era todo distinto la comida
las calles en realidad cuando llegamos
en esta terminal lo más lindo que había
era la comida muchos de nosotros nos
escapamos del hambre y de la falta de
oportunidades con mi hermana nos reímos
y vimos que lo lindo que tenía este país
era la carne
bueno llegamos mis padres seguían con
sus rutinas
en mi mamá trabajaba cama adentro en una
casa de familia de lunes a viernes salía
los sábados
y regresaba los domingos al mediodía
mi papá trabajaba desde las cinco y
media de la mañana y lo veíamos a las
nueve de la noche sí con mi hermana
estudiábamos y comíamos era porque
sabíamos que era lo correcto
me acuerdo que mi abuelo me dijo que
para hacer alguien en la vida tenías que
estudiar
yo lo único que sabía era que alguien
quería hacer
la primaria no fue fácil los niños son
crueles pero no son malos
viví en barrios vulnerables donde habían
problemáticas distintas
los niños generalmente repiten lo que
viven en sus hogares y si uno no le pone
límites hacen las cosas equivocadas en
los barrios donde yo vivía los niños
eran crueles nos insultaban nos decían
bolitas nos trataban mal yo la primaria
no fui a el patio no conozco un recreo
lo miraba por las ventanas
me sentía siempre extraño en uno de los
colegios donde terminé la primaria cerca
del barrio donde estoy viviendo
los tratos serán peores no rompían los
cuadernos nos insultaban nos pegaban nos
escupían que hubieran hecho ustedes si a
sus hijos a esa edad le hubieran tratado
así
o que creen que ustedes se hubieran
hecho
yo que hice
aprendí a defender mi hermana solo
lloraba
y yo sabía que lo que ella estaba
haciendo estaba mal
porque ella pronto dejaría de estudiar
terminó la primaria y la secundaria de
noche yo quería estudiar
aprendí a defenderme tanto que la
primaria nadie me podía pegar me acuerdo
un día la preceptora se dio a la espalda
y veía como una chica del secundario
apareció en mi salón
y yo ese día tenía mucho miedo pero si
la profesora la preceptora no hacían
nada debe ser que mal no estaba así que
ese día feliz
está un poco borrada de memoria porque
no me acuerdo si me pegaron
solo me acuerdo que ese día tomé mucho
valor y sabía que iba a seguir
estudiando
fue difícil la primaria en el barrio en
el que vivía también la delincuencia
había matado muchos compatriotas
por lo tanto creía que los derechos no
existían y mi papá siempre decía que lo
que estaban pagando era el derecho de
piso por lo tanto yo creí que lo que
hacía en el primaria era pagar derecho
de piso cuando llegué a la secundaria
era todo distinto
los chicos que iban a estudiar era
porque buscaban una mejor calidad de
vida nadie los obligaba a ir a la
escuela menos a terminar el secundario
los chicos eran muy amables siempre me
invitaban a sus casas me hablaban todos
pero yo me sentía extraña yo no me
seguía sintiendo bien no iba a los
recreos me invitaban a los bailes como
todo adolescente yo no fui nunca un
baile terminé la secundaria y me acuerdo
en la fiesta de egresados fui con mis
papás recibía el diploma y volví
tenía una sola amiga mi mejor amiga a la
cual había elegido porque era de salta
yo creí que alguien de la provincia
tenía algún parecido conmigo
pasaron los años y yo me seguía
sintiendo mal no era feliz
pero mis compañeros me ayudaban a
integrarme
claro qué es lo que a mí me hacía sentir
mal era una palabra pero cómo hacer que
todos se den cuenta que yo no era
extranjera o como yo hacer para sentirme
bien un día escuché en el barrio donde
vivo que los hijos de peruanos de
paraguayos y de bolivianos no tenían los
mismos derechos yo había estudiado y
sabía que sí que teníamos incluso
herramientas y que teníamos derechos y
obligaciones que éramos ciudadanos igual
a todos y también se sabía que no todos
los argentinos eran malos como no todos
los peruanos eran buenos
el ser mala persona no te distingue por
una nacionalidad lo que yo viví fue una
etapa mala pero que no debía de marcar
mi vida entonces en el barrio donde viví
decidió organizar a mi comunidad y
enseñarle con ejemplos lo que nosotros
vinimos a hacer que es sumar construir
nos escapamos del hambre de la necesidad
de la falta de oportunidades y hoy sigue
pasando esto porque no hay ni mis
compatriotas en distintos países de
latinoamérica donde sigue emigrando hay
desigualdad falta de solidaridad
individualismo y eso no debería de pasar
con nosotros cuando organizamos la
asociación civil latinoamericana de
tigre dentro del barrio
fue para enseñar que nosotros éramos
seres humanos como todos con derechos y
con obligaciones perdonando lo que nos
habían hecho y agradeciendo todo lo que
ustedes nos dieron y lo que me dieron a
mí cuando era niña sufrimos hambre este
país tiene muchas oportunidades de lunes
a viernes nosotros damos el desayuno y
el almuerzo a 100 niños que vienen al
centro y no distinguimos nacionalidad
porque creemos que todos los niños son
iguales y enseñamos a nuestra comunidad
a construir a entender pero cómo hacerlo
es esa palabra extranjero hace 12 años
que yo no me siento más extranjera
yo no soy extranjera extranjero es el
que está de paso el que va a un lugar y
vuelve yo decidí quedarme acá yo decidí
vivir en este país tengo tres hijas hace
12 años que este país me dio esa
oportunidad de sentirme parte de ustedes
les agradezco y quiero que hoy se lleven
todos que si tuvieron un familiar que
fue extranjero que se sintió extranjero
que le digan que no era extranjero que
era el ciudadano más
argentinos que nacimos en distintos
países muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]